what is this
happy holidays the white but do not open
it until Christmas you're so pathetic
how long did this take you three hours
five minutes actually I am a black belt
in gift wrapping yeah
no such thing they don't give out black
belts for things that are stupid well I
hope it was worth it cuz I'm gonna take
it apart in about five minutes I think
I'll take a little bit longer than that
really if I can skin a mule deer in less
than ten minutes
now I'll be able to cut my Leslie wishes
she could be here herself to give you
these presents but she's suspended oh
and also she said that they're not from
her they're from Santa Claus I go first
mouse rat certified gold over 100 copies
sold in Pawnee I need to get a picture
of me holding this so I can frame it
personalized leopard printed robe pink
feather cuffs and on the back in
rhinestones you can get it I know you're
sad you couldn't get tickets to the
Watch the Throne tour so I got you a
watch and a tiny throne instead and
check it out she even took out the dumb
clock part and put this in all the time
these are the Black Eyed Peas
and I finally killed them it's a
Christmas miracle every year I give
Leslie the same president I give
everyone a crisp $20 bill and every year
she gets me something thoughtful and
personal it makes me furious this year
she outdid herself
she had it installed over the weekend so
so beautiful
[Music]
you own this I got a charity - who cares
about they can't give them some shots
they got poured oil first one skinny one
I've got 42 years without a lump of coal
I'm not gonna start now
Merry Christmas why did you bring that
here don't worry she's dead oh wait he's
dead white what I accidentally ran over
it it's a Christmas miracle
we'll get it out of here relax okay and
because this is Christmas I am going to
roast this goose and prepare it with a
wild rice dressing do we have any
cayenne pepper in the kitchen Merry
Christmas twine Jimmy
Wow what we got here what does it look
like dead goose and circle gets the
square so can you watch this I'm gonna
get my carving knife out of the trunk no
Toby this is different he's already dead
once I brought in a duck to prepare for
lunch and people got upset apparently
they got attached to the duck and didn't
want to see it killed he was already
dead
and we schrutes use every part of the
goose the meat has a delicious smoky
rich flavor plus you can use the molten
goose grease and save it in the
refrigerator thus saving you a trip to
the store for a can of expensive goose
grease
Wow when win exactly thank you Jim
I like goose it's already dead is it so
crazy if we did that it's crazy it's
crazy
mmm Dwight you cannot keep that here
okay that is ridiculous and totally
against the spirit of Christmas come on
Dwight we went over this like for a half
an hour it's Christmas dough it's a dead
animal in our office don't we I'm sorry
please please
clean it in your car I would like it off
my desk Oh Pam
take a chill pill oh hey what are you
doing here hey uh I just wanted to tell
you something in person
oh my god I'm pregnant wait what no
that's not it I turned down that
accounting job just didn't feel right
that's okay right yeah I think that's
great I'm really proud of you yeah
what are you gonna do instead I have no
idea I like it well I guess I'll just
see it huh well they're having a party
in here why don't you stay actually I
think you should going along what's
going on here
Merry Christmas Leslie we made you this
replica of the parks department out of
gingerbread oh my god I love it
I love it and I love you guys and Ann
specifically and all of you you did all
of this together
yes except for me turns out I cannot
make a gingerbread house which would
bother me if I were an eight-year-old
girl in any case these people stepped up
and helped me out and that gave me
another idea this is the city council
chambers and that's you next May I don't
understand your campaign advisers quit
big deal you're running for City Council
again Leslie with our help
April Ludgate youth outreach and
director of new media Tom Haverford
image consultant swagger coach and
Perkins office manager and volunteer
coordinator Andy Dwyer security sweets
body man javelin if need be Donna mEagle
Transpo aka rides in my benz well you
guys didn't tell me we were doing this I
I did not know that I was supposed to
come up with something Ron Swanson
damn thing you might need guys it's so
much work I can't ask you to put your
lives on hold find one person here who
you haven't helped by putting your life
on hold I don't know what to say except
let's go win an election
giving Christmas gifts is like a sports
to me finding or making that perfect
something it's also like a sport to me
because I always win this year though my
friends won in fact I got my ass handed
to me you see this I'm about to give
captain Holt his gift oh did he lift his
no gift policy no he didn't but I
figured out a way to buy him something
and trick him into accepting it were bad
I know right oh wait you're making fun
of me mm-hmm well I don't care he would
never open a gift right but what if his
gift it didn't look like a gift
he would open it exactly I left it in a
cardboard box on his desk there's no
card
just the words open now which I wrote
with my wrong hand so we wouldn't
recognize the handwriting
captain Santiago Giraldo sir so just to
recap you left an unmarked package on a
police captain's desk on a random Monday
with a suspicious message written on des
that looked like it was scrawled by a
crazy person
rig if you shut it shove it back here we
go don't bring the branches Dwight I got
splinter now suck it up we all have
problems hey everybody look haha nice
huh
I've got it leveraged Merry Christmas
wait a minute is that Scully four
calling Birds three French hens two
turtle doves and a partridge in a pear
tree
hey guys thought I'd spread the
Christmas cheer cool
so you're just out here caroling solo
yeah I guess you could say that no you
can't he's not solo case came damn right
we did a one A two A one two three yes
they are
you